hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 12 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it there were some really big reveals it
was all about introducing the calculator
and it was part one of a two-part
episode so all the big questions that
you had like the really big ones will be
answered next week I actually didn't
realize that going into this episode so
when they had the big twist at the end I
was like wait this feels like they're
giving us half the story
so I checked the list and yes like all
the characters from this episode will be
in next week's episode
but speaking of which Colton Haynes
probably best performance in the episode
it was very Fault in Our Stars just
careful for spoilers from that movie if
you haven't seen it or if you haven't
read that book is this really tragic
love story about two teens dying from
different diseases they find each other
fall in love is this really
heartbreaking story so any time Roy was
on screen with Thea and she was like she
was coughing like she's gonna die that's
pretty much what it was it was Fault in
Our Stars let's do top 5 WTF then I'll
explain any Easter eggs that don't
really make it into my list starting
with number 5 Nyssa escapes and tries to
find the Lotus shocking twist the Lotus
is actually a device meant to counter
the effects of the Lazarus Pit developed
by the Crescent order which is now who
katana is working with secret
organization central to Japan in the way
that the League of Assassins is central
to Nanda Parbat always happy to see
katana back no I don't really know what
they're gonna do with her character in
the future if all the movie Suicide
Squad characters are killing off their
TV counterparts unofficially but I
thought they did a good job of
acknowledging what happened during
season 3 in a really brief turn of
phrase they almost didn't even need that
they kind of accomplished that with the
long look like yeah some happened
last season my husband died but I found
a new purpose so now to number 4 WTF Roy
is back and he is mysteriously stealing
technology Oliver has to shoot him in
order for them to take him in that was a
big win for felicity she was the one
that knew that something was happening
with Roy so they did that really awesome
reveal where she's like wait Oliver and
then they switched to his perspective so
you can't hear Felicity speak but he's
like all right got it shoots him BAM
you think he's dead they had already
posted the clip of Roy waking up in the
new arrow cave or the foundry whatever
you want to call it so yes I think arrow
is doing a better job of misdirecting us
with you know big WTF moments like
Oliver oh my god he killed Roy but we'll
address that again in a second because I
I think that's what's going on with
DEA's storyline number three WTF Roy
explains the calculator so here's the
deal the calculator is kind of like an
evil Felicity an evil version of Oracle
the Barbara Gordon Oracle in the comics
he's mostly known as the birds of prey
villain he kind of does for villains
what Felicity does for team arrow just
yo hacker extraordinaire anything that
you might need from the digital realm so
he learns about Roy uses him to get all
the tech he needs from Star City so if
everyone were to find out that Roy was
not the arrow originally that would mean
that the arrow is still out there and
they would turn their attention to green
arrow they'd be like oh you're the guy
this guy took the fall for you what does
that remind you of Dark Knight Rises in
Bane revealing that Batman did not kill
all those people
same deal it would just undo a lot of
good work that they had done you may
have picked up on it on his speech with
Oliver but Roy talked to Oliver all like
hey man how do you take the weight of
the world on your shoulders how do you
deal with all this responsibility trying
to take the blame for everything and
that kind of connects with the flashback
arc so number three WTF flashback Oliver
starts hallucinating shadow and it is
shado
but she tells him you're imagining me
the only way out is through your own
darkness but she helps him to realize
that he's being chained down by his
guilt that is his darkness the title of
the episode is Unchained
so naturally he confesses to the woman
that he saved I killed your brother so
he's unchaining himself from his guilt
number two WTF Thea's bloodlust is
eventually going to kill her
Merlyn had this great explainer for
balancing the scales it was a great
metaphor awesome Merlyn episode he's
getting all those great dad moments the
Joe West got on the flash this week so
Merlyn is like the Joe West of arrow
this week even though he's a pretty evil
character sometimes the greatest act of
love is no act at all so the twist is
that Nyssa will give Oliver what he
needs to save Thea but he has to kill
Merlyn so they're gonna follow up on
that in next week's episode the episode
is literally titled sins of the father
it's all about everyone's daddy issues
and trying to resolve those find me a
mainstream comic book character that
does not have daddy issues on some level
what about Thea though is she the one
that's in the grave this really seems
like it's pushing her into that grave
she doesn't have long to live in that
coma she's on the edge of
death the flash board the last
flash-forward we had was I think four
months into the future it might have
been three months which seems a little
too long based on the way the nursemaid
had seen the nurse made it seem like she
had a couple of days to live which makes
me think that they will find a way to
save her without killing Merlin that
just feels like the twist like they want
you to think that thee is gonna die I
feel like they're doing a better job at
misdirecting us than say like in season
three when they wanted us to believe
that Oliver was dead that was one of the
biggest wastes of lazarus pit use that
they could have made so yeah he is gonna
die they're not lying about that but I
feel like they're doing a better job of
making us wonder how they're going to
fix the situation and who's gonna be in
that grip I still feel like it's gonna
be someone else it just feels like
they're laying on the theists stuff way
too thick this week like all of a sudden
BAM she's down you know she's not just
down she's gonna die in a couple days
anytime something feels way too obvious
it probably is think about it this way
if they put thee in the grave then what
is the whole point of Oliver
resurrecting her last season that was
the entire reason for the major arc of
season 3 so they're not gonna do
something that's gonna throw that under
the bus they're not gonna completely
negate the season 3 arc because why
would you save her just to put her back
in the grave but they are gonna have
some fun making you wonder how they're
going to fix this situation that's
really what the more hopeful DC shows
are about like the ones that are a
little bit lighter like yeah people can
die but the hero always finds a way
Superman always finds a way that's why
everyone was so upset when he snapped
Zod's neck at the end a Man of Steel
it's like Superman is the guy that
always finds a way to not kill someone
but that's just my takeaway based on the
information they presented now they
could give us a bunch of new information
next week that'll make us think that
someone else is gonna die or they could
make Thea even worse so it just remains
to be seen so keep your options open
don't completely lock yourself down to
any one theory number one WTF though
this is a little bit more fun Felicity
turns around to say hello to her father
surprise surprise it's the calculator
the weird thing is is that when they
announced that the actor was going to
play the calculator on the show they
also said that he was going to be
Felicity's father so yeah I was a great
moment to end on but they had already
kind of tipped their hat to what the
relationship was going to be between him
and Felicity and they kind of color
scheme the entire episode blue which was
a nice home
two calculators character in the comics
and you can kind of tell when they
started going up against each other you
know Felicity versus calculator the
Caddy banter that the calculator had you
know like the quippy one-liners sounded
very similar to the way that Felicity
talks whenever she's going after someone
so like father like daughter now we know
he wants the battery but we don't know
if he knows that Felicity was the person
he was going up against when they fought
the first time I don't think he had
figured it out but he might have figured
it out in between them blowing up the
factory disabling his bomb and then him
showing up at that presentation so in
this moment neither one of them knows
who each other is because they're both
modulating their voices they're very
good at masking their identities but in
this moment here I think he knows
Felicity is the person who stopped him
so he's just gonna have a little bit of
fun with that isn't she something just
the way he said that line is like yeah I
know that she is the one who stopped me
but she has the tech I need so I'm gonna
have a little bit of fun here playing
the dad card so much fun and like I said
next week's episode called the sins of
the father gonna be all about resolving
this Felicity calculator arc no way
they're gonna kill him off it's just too
much fun for Felicity's character to
have a dad that's evil it's very
different from the Thea Merlyn
relationship because Merlyn kind of
hasn't been that much of a villain
character I think calculator will be
more overtly bad and it'll be really fun
to see how Felicity deals with this but
let me know in the comments what did you
think about the calculator so far
obviously he's gonna be back in next
week's episode he'll be much bigger so
we'll get more felicity vs calculator
scenes which were a lot of fun but I
feel like the best stuff in the episode
where Roy's scenes like what did you
think of Roy I feel like he had more
scenes in this episode than in all of
like season one and two combined
Colton's moving up in the world
everybody give him a high five Brooke
will go matter - I almost forgot there
is a new round of the reverse flash ring
giveaway going on I'll announce the
winner when I post my legends of
tomorrow video all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video you don't have to
say your ending the giveaway you just
leave any kind of comment you want now
they did announce there's gonna be a
Supergirl flash crossover I'll do a
video for that next explaining how it's
gonna work what we know about it so far
it'll be episode 18 of Supergirl flash
will be going on Supergirl
so why you guys wait for that's a post
you can click here for last night's
episode of the flash so it was one of
the best episodes this season so far
I feel like the flash is beginning
better and better with each episode and
you can click here for my Deadpool boobs
video just so much fun
Deadpool is having way too much fun
right now everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight